[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi
12 octobre les titres de cette édition
une journée de la mobilité pour tous à
l'estaca à montigny le bretonneux
l'école d'ingénieurs proposer à ses
étudiants une sensibilisation à la prise
en compte du handicap dans la vie
professionnelle
reportage en début de journal à partir
de demain et pendant tout le week end ce
sont les journées nationales de
l'architecturé un programme riche dans
le département est visible de l'école
nationale supérieure d'architecturé
versailles ou encore découverte de saint
quentin en yvelines à travers son
urbanisme
nous recevons frédéric debussche
directeur du musée de la ville
et puis du sport avec d'anciennes
gloires du football pour un match
caritatif le variétés club de france
affrontait la sélection geodis ir à
poissy une rencontre au profit
d'associations pour laquelle nous étions
sur place
une première à la une de l'actualité
elle concerne l estaca l'école
d'ingénieurs située à montigny le
bretonneux organisé une journée de la
mobilité pour tous à destination de ses
étudiants objectif du rendez-vous
aujourd'hui sensibiliser à la prise en
compte des problématiques du handicap
dans leurs projets actuels ou futurs à
un mois de la semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées
nicolas kirillovitch au premier coup
d'oeil on pourrait croire qu'il s'agit
d'un jet-ski un peu bricolé ever c'est
en fait un kite surf à voile pour des
skippers en situation de handicap
le projet était présenté pour la
première fois par l'association de voile
de l'estaca l'objectif c'était que de
créer un support qui est adapté pour les
ans nationaux surtout pour les
handicapés mais du coup aussi pour les
valides et c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi
cette forme parce qu en fait avec le
lacet halle centrale d'inde jet ski
c'est assez adapté pour les handicapés
pour qu'il soit stable la forme trimaran
aussi parce que ça te permet une grande
stabilité sur l'eau la présentation de
ce prototype s'inscrit dans le cadre de
la première journée mobilité pour tous
organisée par l'école une première pour
sensibiliser les ingénieurs de demain
sur la problématique du handicap de
faire rencontrer les étudiants et les
professionnels sur la thématique de la
mobilité et de le
et la situation d'handicap dans la
mobilité pour
c'est un métier d'avenir c'est un métier
où la population vieillit il faudra
prendre plus en plus en compte ces
difficultés de mobilité au sein de la
conception également de la production
atelier découverte conférences ou encore
animations sportives et est notamment
programmé pour cette journée spéciale
une journée qui a convaincu les
principaux intéressés
ça permet de
justement de casser ses idées reçues de
casser cette gêne vis-à-vis du tpx juste
des gens tout à fait normaux a juste eu
la malchance de se trouver dans ces
fauteuils animer des études ça fait
partie des sujets qu'on aborde pas
spécialement parce que c'est qu'une
petite partie des employés mais du coup
ils sont quand même là et c'est
important de savoir tout ce qui est mis
en oeuvre pour les intégrer l
intégration professionnelle reste encore
une des problématiques principales pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
19 % d'entre eux sont au chômage
aujourd'hui c'est deux fois plus que la
moyenne nationale
elle jusqu'à la fin du mois 7 octobre
rose l'événement de sensibilisation au
cancer du sein qui touche en france ce
près d'une femme sur huit à maurepas
cette semaine une manifestation récolter
des fonds pour la ligue contre le cancer
elle hip hop pink party c'est un cours
découverte de danses et il n'y avait pas
forcément besoin d'être un pro du hip
hop
camille lambert et aurélie ronces
[Musique]
une dominante rose sur des airs de hip
hop voilà les ingrédients de cette
manifestation organisée au gymnase des
baissière à maurepas danser en faveur de
la lutte contre le cancer du sein
c'était l'objectif de l'association
delight
c'est aux membres de l'association en
fait qui a été touché par cette maladie
drake qui voulait elle mener ce combat
là et du coup ben on s'est dit on va la
6 république soutenir dans ce combat
pendant une heure et demie une
quarantaine de participants enchaîner
les mouvements lents et rapides
le court était ouvert à tous une manière
de montrer que tout le monde peut être
touché un jour par cette maladie c'est
une très bonne idée c'est très bien il
faut avoir bien été soigné pour un
cancer donc c'est très bien dans ma
famille un jeune ne veut que un problème
avec son cerveau avec ce genre de
conneries donc mal placé l'homme placé
pour vraiment un cours de hip hop pour
une bonne action puisque l'ensemble des
fonds récoltés sera reversée à la ligue
contre le cancer
[Musique]
dans l'actualité à maurepas encore
c'était une après midi pour trouver sa
mission d'intérêt général un service
civique et dating se tenait au café de
la plage principe du rendez vous
organisé par yveline information
jeunesse et des rencontres rapides avec
des organismes pour trouver son service
civique
cet engagement volontaire pour les 16 25
ans environ 200 missions étaient
proposés mélanie poquet étaient sur
place
geoffrey sera peut-être l'un des deux
jeunes en service civique à la
préfecture des yvelines se mord pas un
de 25 ans actuellement en recherche
d'emploi s'engagerait pour huit mois
enfin communication donc avec la
préfecture et les tâches qu'elle me
donner ça aurait pu ça peut être très
intéressant a donc on adéquation avec ce
que je fais ça va être sympa après moi
je cherche pas un temps plein dont c'est
pour ça que le service civique ça peut
se mettre coaching ça me laissera du
temps de faire des choses à côté pour ce
service civique des teens le réseau
information jeunesse des yvelines a
convié une vingtaine d'organismes du
territoire de 100 missions sont
proposées pour des jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
il peut avoir un amalgame sur l'emploi
donc c'est vrai nom que vous avez
j'insiste 1 c'est bien une mission en
tant que volontaire il donc à beaucoup
de communication a porté sur qu'est ce
que le service civique et après c'est de
les diriger vers la bonne structure
parce qu'un jeune peut faire qu'une fois
un service civique dans sa vie des
services d'état des établissements
scolaires mais aussi des associations
comme celle ci installé à viroflay
elle développe depuis 2015 un gant
connectés et propose deux missions
autour du marketing et de l'innovation
sans le service civique il serait
impossible pour nous de pouvoir
développer aussi facilement en fait ce
type de prototype
ce qu'on souhaite aussi c'est que la
personne à terme elle puisse trouver
plus facilement son emploi et peut-être
même si notre association réussi à
proposer 7 se veut aller jusqu'au stade
d'un produit lui permettre de même de
l'embauché des missions dans les
yvelines en france et même à l'étranger
en 2016 plus de 90 mille volontaires ont
réalisé un service civique
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure dans
les titres un rendez vous à ne pas
manquer ce week end la deuxième édition
des journées nationales de
l'architecturé en ile de france c'est
une centaine d'événements programmés et
dans les yvelines par exemple c'est
l'occasion de découvrir à l'école
nationale supérieure d'architecturé
versailles qui ouvre ses portes au
public
camille lambert vous y emmène un lieu
d'exception pour un enseignement
d'exception c'est ici face au château de
versailles dans ces bâtiments classés
monuments historiques qui a imaginé le
monde de demain
1200 futurs architectes conçoivent
chaque jour des réalisations innovantes
en ce moment nous on travaille sur dans
une grande pièce avec deux fenêtres de
part et d'autre et en fait on cherchait
à créer un courant d'air et à venir
récupérer le son du coup de l'extérieur
on pour ça on a créé un tube avec des
encres noires et des enseignants
d'architecturé de design et d'arts
plastiques qui se mettent ensemble et
qu'il faut travailler sur des étudiants
sur des installations sonores dans
l'école ça apprend que le son n'est pas
forcément un ennemi de l'architecte
c'est à dire que le son c'est une
qualité positive des espaces arts
plastiques sciences et ingénierie une
formation pluridisciplinaire pour
répondre aux enjeux sociaux économiques
et écologiques du monde qui nous entoure
cent dix neuf enseignants accompagne
durant cinq ans les étudiants et pousse
la réflexion autour de l'avenir de
l'architecturé sédar senghor de demain
je vous dirai pas si elle est si l
envers en métal si lé point dessus ou
rondes
peu importe je pense qu'elle sera
surtout capable de
beaucoup moins consommatrices l'école
favorise un terrain qui invite les
étudiants à chercher à construire à
prendre position pour améliorer sans
cesse il ya une très belle formule
d'hannah arendt ce qui dit les activités
humaines ne peuvent prétendre à
l'excellence
si on ne leur offre pas le terrain pour
s'accomplir un terrain qui sera ouvert
au public lors des journées nationales
de l'architecturé l'occasion de
découvrir l'escalier de la curiosité qui
présente une année de travaux
d'étudiants des visites guidées en
musique seront également proposés elle
est journée nationale d'architecturé qui
prendront également tout leur sens à
saint quentin en yvelines une balade en
bus et à pied est proposé samedi de 14
heures à 17 heures point de départ le
musée de la ville pour découvrir ensuite
l'histoire de l'agglomération au travers
de son architecture et de son urbanisme
bonsoir frédéric debussche vous êtes le
directeur du musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines alors l'histoire du
territoire qui est une thématique on
peut dire centrale cette année pour le
musée de la ville puisque on le rappelle
avant de parler avant de parler de cette
balade jusqu'à la fin de l'année il ya
une exposition qui se tient au musée de
la ville sur l'histoire de saint quentin
en yvelines
une exposition permanente et fait qui
monte qui se tient au musée de la ville
une exposition qui retrace l'évolution
de ces territoires dans le cadre du
label ville d'art et d'histoire
également on appelle ça la siat un
centre d'interprétation de
l'architecturé et du patrimoine qui est
destiné à rappeler les grandes étapes de
l'évolution de ce territoire et
notamment l'essor de la ville nouvelle à
partir des années soixante dix alors là
cette balade samedi est donc consacrée à
l'évolution de saint quentin en yvelines
mais au travers son architecture et de
son urbanisme
pourquoi ce qui est ce que c'est
intéressant d'observer cette évolution
justement le de l'urbanisme et
l'architecturé à 50 en yvelines parce
que les villes nouvelles sont des villes
assez atypique est assez rare il ya eu
neuf villes nouvelles créées en france
de façon autoritaire par le pouvoir par
les gouvernements dans les années 70
dont cinq en ile de france et c'est un
urbanisme qui qui rompt avec l'urbanisme
des années précédentes et notamment
celle de l'immédiate après guerre des
années 50 60
en essayant de proposer un modèle
de vie et de villes nouvelles qui
essayent de mêlée à la fois la résidence
en proximité avec le lieu de travail un
accord en connexion aussi avec les les
transports et des bâtiments qui doivent
pousser vite voici à l'époque j'imagine
oui les constructions que ceux
relativement rapide puisque la ville
nouvelle de saint quentin va sortir de
terre en une quarantaine d'années donc
une ville champignon est qui qui prend
comme le temps de se construire et qui
ne part pas d'un terrain totalement
vierge puisque il y avait naturellement
des villages anciens sur sur ce
territoire une vie nouvelle
ce sont avant tout des anciens villages
alors la balade en bus à pied vous
conduira à travers plusieurs lieux
emblématiques de l'agglomération je
pense au quartier 17 marée l'encours le
manuel et les arcades du lac à montigny
le bretonneux ou encore villa roi à
guyancourt y aura bien d'autres lieux
encore pourquoi emmené public sur ces
lieux finalement qu'est ce que ça nous
apprend c'est luc et que nous apprennent
t-il sur l'histoire de saint quentin
pour découvrir cette ville nouvelle il
faut il faut bouger puisque la
communauté d'agglomération aujourd'hui
ce sont douze communes qui correspondent
à peu près aux communes historique de
l'algérie en est le principe c'est donc
un territoire relativement étendue à
cheval sur plusieurs plusieurs anciennes
communes enfin qu'est la commune qui
subsiste est lente il faut aller d'un
endroit à un autre pour saisir
l'évolution la construction de cette
ville mon amour pas on a à la fois le
témoignage de l'ancien village mais
aussi l'essor de cette ville qui avait
été amorcée en fait dès les années 60
avec dès la création de sites et les si
terrible faite par un entrepreneur et
qui proposait déjà un modèle d'urbanisme
en rupture avec les les bars et les
tours qu'on faisait dans les années 50
cette mare elle en cours on a un
urbanisme qui marque le début historique
de la ville nouvelle avec un ensemble à
sable et matic les vagues qui ont été
inauguré en 1975 et qui marque
d'ailleurs le début la ville nouvelle
qui va après plutôt se glisser vers pour
avoir un centre plus défini autour d'un
facteur de montigny très bien et est
ainsi de suite jusqu au bâtiment qui est
peut-être le plus emblématique de dôme
de saint quentin qui est qu'ils sont les
arcades du lac construite par au regard
de bush il grand architecte espagnol qui
proposera un modèle tout à fait tout à
fait intéressant de ce qu'on appelle le
postmodernisme en architecture et qui
renouvelle aussi le langage
architectural des années 70-80 en
essayant de s'inspirer de l'architecturé
ancienne alors vous parliez de mort pas
rester avec nous nous aurons un sujet
sur les 50 ans de la ville à une
exposition qui se tient en ce moment à
maurepas une dernière question puisque
le temps défile vous êtes vous le
directeur de ce musée de la ville depuis
août dernier il le musée la ville un qui
je le précise est installé depuis
janvier au muy m'aide à montigny le
bretonneux
quelles sont vos perspectives voilà dans
ce nouveau poste les prochains temps
forts aussi à venir au musée de la ville
alors il ya une actualité en cours une
prochaine exposition va s'ouvrir à
partir du 8 novembre sur le thème de la
télévision qui va marquer donc la fin de
l'année
2017 et qui va se poursuivre jusqu'en
jusqu'à l'année prochaine juillet va
suivre une exposition sur le sport en
lien avec la ryder cup
et oui voilà notre position de
circonstances mais le musée comme la
ville d'art et d'histoire propose aussi
des activités parallèles en visitant
conférence par exemple pendant les
vacances de delà de la sara qui arrive à
grands pas plusieurs acteurs ateliers
pédagogiques proposées pour les enfants
à partir de 5 6 ans sur le thème
justement de la ville et de la
construction moderne
merci frédéric lemieux d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle vous êtes le directeur
du musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines qui donc ce musée la ville
propose samedi une balade en bus et à
pied au travers de saint quentin en
yvelines pour découvrir l'architecturé
l'urbanisme de ce territoire
le circuit sera commenté la visite et
sur inscription toutes les coordonnées
du musée de la ville sont à retrouver
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
petite pause sportive dans ce journal
l'ambiance était au grand soir hier au
stade léo lagrange de poissy 2260 10e
match caritatif pour le variétés club de
france sur le terrain plusieurs
champions du monde 98 comme christian
karembeu laurent blanc où l'actuel
sélectionneur des bleus à didier
deschamps
elle est denis les spectateurs présents
ont pu voir également le joueur du paris
saint-germain hatem benarfa résumé de la
soirée avec mickaël landreau soirée de
gala à poissy sur la même pelouse au
stade léo lagrange didier deschamps
christian karembeu laurent blanc ou
encore alain giresse
ils ont tous répondu présent à l'appel
du variétés club de france pour ce match
caritatif contre une équipe composée
d'amateurs ont fait un coup qui se
questionnent notre action à la retraite
donc je trouve ça cool surtout que
du défunt l'était hier au stade de
france françois cool qu'ils soient venus
les deux mille supporters présents ont
même pu apercevoir un petit nouveau au
sein du variétés florent malouda
finaliste de la coupe du monde 2006 je
sais pas s'il veut mais c'est vrai que
les corps que vous commencez donc oui
mais après bon il ya tellement de
joueurs que avec la fatigue on va gérer
mais ça va j'ai pas j'ai pas de soucis
ce niveau là mais l'attraction du soir
se nommer le joueur habitué au banc de
touche au psg à créditer le public d'une
grosse prestation pour son premier match
officiel de la saison
passement de jambes accélérations et
même passe décisive sur le premier but
de la rencontre
j'ai couru je me suis donné quand même
si je suis un peu fatigué mais c'est
normal quand on est sur le terrain pour
il faut donner ce qu'on a donc
donc voilà très content quelques minutes
après l'ouverture du score l'équipe
geodis adverse égalise le tableau
d'affichage n'évoluera plus score final
un but partout
c'est sympa parce que sur l' affaire
n'aurait même a mérité on a beaucoup
d'opportunités on a fini plus fort que
les petits jeunes
j'étais sur la polo à face donc c'est
sympa pas de vainqueur sur la pelouse
mais une grande victoire en dehors du
terrain les bénéfices de la rencontre
ont permis de récolter 15 mille euros en
faveur des associations urbain et plus
de vie soutenu par bernadette chirac
présente ce mercredi au stade de poissy
le variétés club de france devrait
revenir l'année prochaine dans les
yvelines pour assurer une nouvelle fois
le show et quelques heures avant le
début du match du variétés club de
france poissy recevait un autre invité
de marque sébastien chabal
l'ancien rugbyman du quinze de france
est venu inaugurer le sport libre de
saint-exupéry en présence notamment de
christian karembeu une aire de street
workout l'espace en accès libre permet
de faire du sport sur des agrès en plein
air une activité qui tient à coeur à
sébastien chabal on écoute au micro de
michael et demi d'euros donc un de ma
reconversion j'ai développé cette
activité cette activité avec eux une
ambition c'est de promouvoir la pratique
sportive
alors aujourd'hui en droit
une démonstration sur des équipements
mais l'équipe en lui-même n'est que la
partie immergée de l'iceberg
la partie visible pardon de l'iceberg
parce que en dessous ce qu'on ne voit
pas c'est qu'on met à disposition des
heures de coaching en finance portée des
rendez vous réguliers sur les
équipements ce qui permettra de suivre
chaque utilisateur de créer du lien
social du bien intergénérationnel il ya
une appli mobile aussi qui est dédiée
aux équipements pour permettre aux gens
de comprendre comment pratiquer comme
antoine sauf il est à découvrir en
apesanteur jusqu'au 20 octobre bonsoir
dec artistes plasticiens designers vous
exposez au conservatoire désordre
montigny le bretonneux apesanteur c'est
le nom de votre exposition visible
depuis le 25 septembre
elle montre des peintures installations
grandiose le tout mise en perspective on
va en parler dans dans un instant par an
est déjà de votre parcours vous êtes né
à annecy en 1968 et vous avez été
notamment journaliste pour la chaîne de
télé locale télé 8 mont blanc pourquoi
se dédiant ensuite à l'art qu'est ce qui
a fait finalement ce changement dans
votre vie j'ai commencé par faire de la
après je me suis dit pourquoi pas aller
voir autre chose donc que j'avais une
envie d'enfant c'était de faire du
journaliste j'ai une opportunité de
travailler quelques temps dans une
chaîne de télé locale
et puis après je parie ma plaie et je
suis revenu à paris pour continuer mes
études de designers alors vous avez une
approche industrielle de larves ou
travaillent énormément l'acier et le
verre le style bec
concrètement c'est quoi je sais pas si
on peut dire qu'il ya des il ya il ya un
style mais j'essaye de
de toucher plusieurs médias je l'avais
de la peinture de l'huile des encres je
fais des installations en bois je fais
des sculptures en acier
je peux faire du vitrail aussi je peux
faire des compositions en verre je peux
faire des installations qui sont plus ou
moins interactive où les gens peuvent
participer pour une idée c'est apporter
des fois des éléments sonores de la
vidéo aussi certaines oeuvres
on va voir dans cette exposition
justement il ya il ya quelque chose en
rapport avec cela mais ouais c'est pour
donner un petit peu plus de profondeur à
vos oeuvres
on peut dire du profondeur du mouvement
épique les gens ne soient pas passif
c'est vrai que là c'est une toile je
fais de l'art abstrait donc on dit moi
je je j'aime à dire aux gens il faut que
vous soyez vous vous soyez pénétrer par
l'oeuvre
vous mettez devant et il faut klaus vous
pénètre pour qu'elle vous parle c'est
comme un peu comme de la musique on met
un casque on se met dans une église et
on est pénétrée par la musique c'est un
peu pareil avec ma peinture et les
installations l'idée d'installation
c'est quand même que le spectateur soit
acteur dans l'installation puissent se
promener dans la station cet été j'étais
présent à monte cristo j'ai fait une
fabrique musicale est en fait les gens
pouvaient jouer la musique c'est un
moment mais pouvait émettre des sons à
l'installation et d'autres pouvaient
observer donc les spectateurs deviennent
acteurs et avec les peintures je fais
pareil en fait je pars d'une peinture
que je retravaille en numérique et via
une application et grâce aux smartphones
les gens
scan la la peinture et il ya une
animation donc d'aller des peintures
qu'on voit actuellement ce sont les deux
peintures qui qui s'anime lecteurs
smartphones des visions augmenté
finalement sur la réalité augmentée je
sais et je fais une composition me vais
pas dire musicale parce qu'il aura les
musiciens font grimper aux murs mais une
je fais une composition sonore derrière
qui accompagne mon travail alors vous
l'avez dit vous avez exposé auparavant
au château de monte-cristo là c'est le
conservatoire des arts des grandes
hauteurs de plafond une verrière qui
donne aussi beaucoup de lumière à la fin
au lieu j'imagine que aussi vous avez
travaillé en fonction du lieu pour
présenter cette exposition a
complètement quand je fais une
exposition individuelle
il ya un travail autour des dieux et
l'exposition est fait pour les lieux
donc pour pour montigny 80% des oeuvres
qui sont présentées à montigny sont des
oeuvres nouvelles complètes complètement
été créé pour pour les lieux après
suivant les lieux et il peut y avoir
plus ou moins dhr deux reprises d'oeuvre
quand été ferrand et j'en fais toujours
plus parce qu'au moment de la mise en
scène
je fais des choix et il ya une partie
des oeuvres qui repartent à l'atelier
sans être exposé sur le titre de
l'exposition apesanteur est-ce que c'est
lié aussi à ses installations vous avez
mis un peu en apesanteur ya un travail
aussi peut-être pour la légèreté des
oeuvres pour que ça puisse on rentre
dans la
dans cette grande salle où on à ces
échelles qui sont suspendus qui donne
l'impression de tenir tout seul dans les
airs derrière on a on a trois
installations on a un coût puisque j'ai
appelé duo où ces deux personnages
jaunes et rouges qui peuvent bouger
ainsi un courant d'air ou six qui les
gens parce que l'ama les les personnages
je joue entre eux et ce tout schuss
touche pas ou ne peuvent émettre des
sons il y à une installation avec des
écorces qui est qui est en fait c'est un
travail que j'ai fait par rapport aux
écorces qui tombe des platanes et en
fait c'est le redonner vie et elle
s'élève dans dans l'espace il ya un jeu
avec la lumière avec les ondes sur le
mur et la dernière installation qu'il ya
dans la deuxième salle derrière c'est
une installation on va dire plus
industriel parce que les cds personnage
c'est un travail autour de de la
rencontre de la société et je travaille
à partir d'un matériau qui s'appelle le
dis bon qui est un matériau qu'on
utilise en signalétique qui est un
matériau imputrescible donc je fais un
dg dessiner des mes personnages l'effet
l'usiné et après je les remets en forme
et je les repeints parce que je rajoute
de la couleur parce que la couleur avec
quelque chose d'important dans mon
travail et après je les mets en gelée
mais en espace et en par rapport à la
salle l'espace où je suis merci d'avoir
été avec nous je le rappelle à votre
exposition apesanteur est à voir
jusqu'au 20 octobre au conservatoire des
arts de montigny le bretonneux et pour
plus d'informations sur votre actualité
les téléspectateurs peuvent se rendre
sur votre site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
et puis un retour à maurepas pour
refermer ce journal la ville fête ses 50
ans pour l'occasion l'association mort
pas d'hier et d'aujourd'hui a lancé
l'exposition une exposition liée à ses
50 ans elle est à découvrir jusqu'au 22
octobre à l'espace albert camus de
maurepas camille lambert et mélanie
poker
rené de c est l'une des plus anciennes
habitants de maurepas alors ce qui est
exposé aujourd'hui elle connaît bien
mort pendant 60 tués nous nous lorsque
nous sommes arrivés nous avions les
pieds dans la boue mais vraiment
complètement dans la boue les rues
n'étaient même pas ni sablé ni rien ça a
été juste dégager
avec les avec les machines l'exposition
a été pensé par l'association mort pas
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui du bourg à la
ville la commune à 50 ans cette année
les archiver et les souvenirs ont été
sortis avant c'était une ferme en fait
donc le fermi allait cesser ces faits
ces terres est donc bon repas s'est
construit en fait sur les terres
agricoles de l'ap qu'on appelle le plein
de la chaux et puis au fur et à mesure
les quatre les quartiers se sont
construit donc on a commencé par la
prévent dry la malle me donne les
baissière tous les quartiers ne mord pas
se sont développées très vite en cinq
six ans et après on a bien sûr ça a
continué avec les promenades au fur et à
mesure des années quand on est besoin
d'aller à la pharmacie on allait à la
verrière alors où traverser la nationale
10 à pied ouais avec deux petits et un
bébé dans une poussette
c'était un exploit l'exposition évolué
de l' architecture pensée par jacques
riboud à l'intérieur d'une maison des
années 60
les enfants découvrent ainsi des objets
inconnus comme ce moulin à café que
certains ont cru être une boîte à
musique
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal on se
donne rendez-vous lundi pour une
nouvelle semaine d'actualité locale sur
tv 60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]